question qu'on peut se poser c'est
comment cette urgence at-elle été
anticipé on a connu un état d'urgence
très important au printemps dernier qui
a conduit le gouvernement à mettre la
france dans un état de confinement total
j'ose espérer que des leçons ont été
prises de cette montée rapide d'un virus
qu'on ne connaît pas dont on ne maîtrise
pas tellement les le système de
d'expansion je trouve aujourd'hui qu'on
se retrouve dans une situation assez
proche de celle d'avril avec des
hôpitaux qui crient au secours partout
en france du manque de personnel voilà
je trouve que l'organisation autour de
cette deuxième vague n'est peut-être pas
celle que nous aurions pu espérer pas
force est constater qu'aujourd'hui on
voit là les hôpitaux créé au secours
qu'on manque de lits de réanimation
pour l'instant on n'entend pas parler de
manque de respirateurs ou de manque de
curare comme ça a été le cas au
printemps dernier mais en tout cas on
manque de lits au manque de personnel et
je trouve
voilà que peut-être on aurait pu mieux
anticiper un coup aussi difficile que
cette deuxième vague qui s'annonce assez
importante